we have mois nous avons un message clair
oui l'ukraine mérite une perspective
européenne jai ho pin prospect of
oui l'ukraine doit être accepté comme un
pays candidat macho
décès sont en sachant que du bon travail
a déjà été fait mais que beaucoup reste
à faire sur 8 miles to vidal
et entend tout de suite pauline godard
notre envoyé spécial à kiev pauline
bonsoir cette recommandation de la
commission européenne est la première
étape on le sait avant ce vote au sommet
européen la semaine prochaine quels sont
les réactions à kiev
et bien c'est une très bonne nouvelle
pour la majorité des ukrainiens selon un
récent sondage
91% d'entre eux veulent cette adhésion
son cours cette adhésion à l'union
européenne beaucoup se sentent déjà
européens nous ont confié plusieurs
ukrainien avec qui nous avons pu parler
c'est un signe très positif qui est
envoyé à l'ukraine par l'europe et puis
le président volodymyr zeddine ce qui a
évidemment au lieu aussi réagi il parle
d'une décision historique c'est le
premier pas sur le chemin de l'adhésion
à l'union européenne qui va certainement
rapprocher notre victoire on vient
d'entendre ursula von der leyen lac la
présidente de la commission de europe de
l'union européenne elle l'a précisé un
il reste encore beaucoup à faire
notamment en ce qui concerne tout ce qui
est anti corruption l'une lutter contre
la corruption en ukraine maintenant il
va falloir convaincre les 27 vous en
parliez puisque certains pays comme le
danemark ou encore les pays-bas ont
exprimé des réserves quant à ce statut
de candidat que pourrait octroyer
l'union européenne à l'ukraine henry
faut l'unanimité des 27 pour prendre ses
décisions
ce seront que décidée lors du conseil
européen qui aura lieu les 23 et les 24
juin prochain
pauline boris johnson est arrivé à kiev
au lendemain de la visite des quatre
présidents de l'union européenne c'est
une sorte de coup dur pour les européens
qu'est ce qu'il fait à kiev
on connaît boris johnson il aime bien
les coups d'éclat et c'est sans doute ce
qu'il est venu faire ici en ukraine
c'est la deuxième fois que le premier
ministre britannique vient ici à kiev il
s'est rendu ici où nous nous trouvons
sur cette place où se trouve derrière
moi la cathédrale saint michael mais où
se trouvent également des chars russes
qui ont été exposés nous comprenons que
l'ukraine ne soit pas disposé à négocier
avec la russie at il expliqué une façon
de rebondir sur ce qu'a dit hier le
président macron lorsqu'il était à kiev
il a parlé avec le président les
hellènes ski notamment de renforcer les
sanctions contre la russie mais aussi de
l'aide économique
c'est bien d'être à nouveau à kiev a dit
boris johnson et de son côté boulot
diverses et dance qui a déclaré je suis
ravi de voir le grand ami de notre pays
boris johnson à kiev plusieurs personnes
avec qui nous avons pu parler juste
après séville 10 mhz cette visite nous
ont dit être ravi de voir boris johnson
ici c'est un homme havre est lui un vrai
lui il agit il ne parle pas ça fait
toute la différence
merci pauline pauline godey en direct de
kiev